camera shots of Taylor Swift
I swear this is where to go to here
a lot of people have accused Taylor Swift of overreacting
I wanna talk about why having a completely neutral reaction as a woman
to a sexist joke by a man is deemed as an overreaction by the patriarchy
I'm Doctor Zoe
I have a PhD in digital feminist activism
so let's talk about it
so for example
the term resting bitch face is pretty much reserved for women
I never really hear anyone refer to men as having a resting bitch
and that's because women are expected to appease and smile and passively accept
and I guess give permission for men to be assholes
we are expected to kind of smile and get over it and make it all pleasant
and we spend a lot of our time and energy
um because we're socialised to
um doing this
so when we begin to reject that
we actually have to work there sometimes
we have to work it
you know saying actually no
I don't wanna do that
and actually no
I don't have to smile for you
and Taylor Swift didn't even react aggressively or pull any sort of bad face
she just basically refused to smile at the joke
that wasn't actually really a joke at all
and no wonder
I think she has a very valid reason for not finding it funny
because American football has basically cheered her up and spat her up
like they've used her milked her
taken advantage of her and the market that she brought in
like the awareness that I've been able to achieve
through association with her has been
you have absolutely capitalised on that until the team started doing badly
and then she was used as a scapegoat to blame basically
so she's probably very recently experienced what it feels like
and what Posh Spice experienced um
years ago when Beckham with this
this exact same thing happened
they blamed posh like oh
she's you know
she's being a distraction to the game
that's why Beckham isn't doing well
she's probably very recently experienced this feeling of feeling like she's been
used and milk to throw it's worth
and then she's there to also blame when
when the team doesn't do that well
which I mean
I know Taylor Swift is very powerful
but is she that powerful that she can control
the sports performance of a whole team of men
so then for them to make this joke
I understand that it's a lazy joke
it's lazy writing
and it's just not very funny
and I don't really think she has to have any sort of reaction to it
and she didn't
she just sipped her drink and refused to smile
but when you refuse to smile as a woman
you're labelled as the aggressor
because being neutral as a woman is not being neutral
it seems being aggressive
cause we are expected and socialised to appease and make room for
and be okay with men
and you know
there was an implicit question in his joke which is
are you gonna let me get away with this
and she was kinda like
no not really
I'm not like
we hold more power
like you know
Barbie Taylor Swift
all of these amazing
you know like Ali Long
these are powerful women
and those jokes are the jokes of men who are struggling
who are in crisis
because they don't know how to make jokes anymore
because they don't know how to survive in a world
where their jokes are not funny anymore
like they were never funny
but they're definitely not funny anymore